introduction so uh there we talk about
approximating the total variation
distance between two product
distributions this talk is based on two
joint works the first one is the join
work with Mark and Jan this work is for
the randomized approximation algorithm
and the next one is based on a joint
work with t and Le this is based this is
a deterministic approximation algorithm
to this problem so this talk is a very
basic and I mainly focus on the
randomized algorithm which is a very
simple arent so feel free to stop me if
you have any
questions okay so uh the problem is that
uh suppose we are given two discrete
distributions p and Q over a finite
domain Omega and a natural question is
how to measure the difference between
two probability distributions so there
are many standard Notions to estimate
the differences for example we have the
total variation distance we have a k
Divergence and other divergencies
so in this talk we focus on the total
variation distance a TV distance between
two distributions and just to recall the
definition given two distributions p and
Q their total variation distance is I
inate all possible X from the domain GA
and I look at the probability of X in p
and the probability of X in Q take their
difference sum over all X together and
divide the whole sum by two this is the
standard definition of the total
variation distance and equivalently uh
it can be defined as we find a subset of
the stat base so subset of stat base is
a event in the probability space and we
look at the uh what is the probability
of this event in p and what is this what
is the probability of this event as in Q
and we take their difference we find the
uh event that maximize the difference
which also equivalent to define the
total variation
distance so you just talking about
discrete probabilities discr
distributions uh probability
distributions so discrete or continuous
uh discrete so this Omega is always a
finite discrete uh set
okay so okay by this picture is a
continuous okay sorry for confusing yet
okay okay just uh uh just give you
intuition the total variation distance
is roughly the the area of this region
okay which is the probability that is in
P but not in Q uh this area is the same
as this area because of the
Symmetry okay so a total variation
distance have a many good properties for
example it is a metric and it can be
characterized in different ways which
actually gives us many different ways to
analyze the total variation distance
between two distributions for example if
you follow this definition then we can
pick an arbitary event s and look at the
difference this will give us a lower
bound of the total variation
distance so it has many applications for
example it can be used to define the
mixing ter of micro CH and it also uh
used in many other
places so but in many applications such
as analyzing the mixing time of micro
chain we only need to analyze the lower
or the upper bound of the total
variation distance but in this work we
consider the computational problem so
the problem is that given the
description of two distributions p and Q
and we want to compute their total
variation
distance so by definition there is a
trivial algorithm so we can just
enumerate all the state in this space
Omega and we sum over the
differences but the challenge part is
that
uh distribution p and Q may have succin
descriptions which makes the sample
space exponentially large with respect
to the input size so this trivia Alm is
a snow in this case there are many
examples of such distributions for
example the graphical models in machine
learning and the spin system in
physics so uh perhaps one of the most
simplest example is the product
distribution so what is the product
distribution we have a fin domain s you
can view it as the the set of one two 3
up to S and we have n distributions P1
P2 and PN every Pi is a distribution
over this domain s and we Define p as
the product distribution of P1 P2 and
PN so in other words if we if we draw a
random sample from the product
distribution P this random sample is a
UND dimensional random vector and in
every index I XI is an independent
sample from the distribution Pi so uh by
this definition we can easily to see
that for every nend dimensional random
Vector X the probability that X appears
in the distribution p is just the
product of all pxi because uh every ixi
is sampled independently from the
distribution p
so to describe the product distribution
we only need to Define this m marginal
distributions and every marginal
distribution Pi is defined over the set
s so we just need s numbers to define
the distribution Pi which is what is the
probability Pi takes value one takes
value two and so on so the input size is
SM because we have M marginal
distributions but the sample space of
this product distribution is s to the N
which is exponentially large with
respect to the input
size so here is the uh computational
problem we considered in this work so
the input uh we input the two product
distributions p and Q over the over the
sample space s to the m here p is
described by m marginal distributions
and Q is also described by a marginal
distributions and the algorithm want to
Output their total variation
distance okay so uh this problem is uh
initiated by B cha at all in last year
and in their paper they Pro they proved
an interesting result um they shows that
even in the Boolean case which means s
equals 2 uh exact Computing of the total
variation distance between p and Q the
sh be
complete so uh this hardness results
motivates the study of approximation
algorithms so in this work we consider
two kinds of approximation algorithm the
first is a deterministic algorithm so
the input contain Arrow bound Epsilon
and the algorithm has to Output a number
D hat such that a d hat approximate the
total variation distance in relative
error and the running time of the
deterministic approximation algorithm we
call it fpus the running time should be
a polinomial in the input size and one
over
EPS so uh we also studed FP which is a
relaxed version in this case the
algorithm is allowed to Output a random
number DH hat such that DH hat
approximate the true total variation
distance with probability at least
2/3 okay so uh let's see uh what is the
results of the previous work so the
previous work give both SE pitas and
fpas for the total variation distance
between two product distributions
however uh their algorithm only works
for special class of product
distributions so they require the
distribution to be Boolean and one of
the distribution only have a constant
number of distin marginals say the
distribution PE sorry the distribution Q
can be the uniform distribution in the
Boolean domain in this case every
marginal distribution is the uniform
distribution over zero and a one so they
are only one distinct marginals but in
general they they may allow distribution
Q have a constant many of distinct
marginal
distributions and their randomized
approximation algorithm can work for
other class of product distributions but
still have some additional conditions so
here is a natural open question so can
we give fpas or fpas for the total
variation distance between General
product
distributions so uh here is our results
uh uh I have two works on this problem
uh one of them give fpus and the other
give fpus both of them works for General
product distributions the running time
of the deterministic approximation
algorithm is roughly o t n s of Epsilon
log one over the total variation
distance so we may assume every marginal
distribution uh in the input is given in
binary so this log one over total
variation distance is a polinomial in
the input size and our randomized
algorithm is even faster the running
time is O2 n^ s over Epsilon
squ
okay uh our deterministic algorithm can
slightly go beyond the product
distribution one example is that we can
estimate the total variation distance
between two micro CH so uh what is the
definition so uh what is the micro CH so
micro CH can be defined by its initial
distribution pi and the transition
Matrix M so a endep micro chent X1 X2 xn
can be generated by with first sample X1
from the initial distribution and we
sample XK using the transition Matrix
and State XK minus one so we can sample
X1 X2 up to XK similarly we can sample
y1 Y2 up to Y up to YN so we have two n
dimensional random vectors and our
algorithm can estimate the total
variation distance between these two
vectors um okay this is our main results
so any question about the problem
definition and the
result okay uh now I will describe our
algorithm so in this talk I will mainly
focus on the randomized algorithm
because this algorithm is very
simple now before I introduce our
algorithm let's think a a very natural
estimator for the total variation
distance so by definition the total
variation distance between p and Q can
be written in this form we enumerate all
X in the state space such that the
probability of X in Q is greater than PX
then we sum over or QX minus PX so this
is a equivalent definition of the total
variation distance then we can take the
Q out and write the total variation
distance in this
form so this give us a natural estimator
to the total variation distance we can
define a random variable R which is the
ratio of PX over QX such that X is a
random sule from the distribution CU and
using this form we can easily verify
that the the total variation distance
between p and Q is the expectation of
max0 one minus r of this random variable
R and for product distribution this
random variable R is easy to sample from
because we can first draw a random
sample X from Q then we can compute PX
and QX we take the ratio then we can get
a random sample
from so okay so here is a very simple uh
algorithm we can draw uh random sample
of R and for every random sample we
compute Max Z one minus r and take
average so it is easy to show that this
logorithm is an unbiased estimator to
the total variation distance uh but
however this lgorithm can only
approximate approximate the TV distance
with additive error which means the
algorithm output a random number D hat
such that with high probability D hat is
within the range total variation
distance plus or minus
but in the problem I defined before what
we want is the D hat that approximate
the total variation distance with
relative arror so one can say can we can
we use the additive arror to get the
relative error approximation in this
case the additive arrrow should be
Epsilon times the total variation
distance but the total variation
distance itself can be exponentially
small so which requires this algorithm
to draw exponentially many number
samples to achieve the relative
approximation
error so this simple idea does not work
for this
problem uh Al so next I will uh
introduce our randomized algorithm
namely our estimator to this problem uh
but I I should remark that although this
naive estimator does not work but this
raal random variable actually captures
the full information of the total
variation distance so in the end of this
talk I will tell you how to use this
ratio random variable to get a
deterministic approximation or to the
total variation distance but now let's
focus on let let let us let me first
introduce what is the randomized
algorithm now to introduce our randomiz
logorithm I need to introduce what is
the coupling between two probability
distributions now suppose we have two
distributions the p and Q defined over
the domain Omega and a coupling here p
and Q can be arbitary distributions not
necessarily the product distribution
okay a coupling of p and Q is a joint
distribution of two random variable X
and Y such that X follows p and Y
follows
Q uh the random variable X and Y can be
correlated with each other as long as
their marginal distribution is
correct so let me show you a simple
example suppose the p is a uniform
distribution between zero and one and Q
is another distribution between zero and
one which take a value zero with the
probability one over
three so a simple example of the
coupling is the independent coupling
that is we sample X from p and a y from
Q
independently if we do in this way then
we can think in this coupling the
probability of X not equal to Y is one/
two uh but uh we can uh next I will
introduce another coupling that makes
this probability smaller so here is
another way to couple the distribution p
and Q we first sample a random real
number R between zero and one uniformly
random then uh we set the variable X to
be zero if R smaller than one/ two and
we set a random variable I random
variable y to be zero if R smaller than
q0 which is one over three and X and Y
are defined using the same random
variable
so it is easy to see that X and Y
follows the correct marginal
distribution but in this case X and Y
are correlated with each other because
they are defined using the same random
variable R so in this case if x not
equal to Y if and only if R fall into
this interval so we can show that in
this case the probabil in this coupling
the probability that X not equal to Y is
the one six which is exactly the total
variation distance between p and Q
actually this is the minimum probability
we can achieve among all all possible
couplings so in general we have the
following
LMA uh which is called coupling
inequality so for any two distributions
p and Q for any coupling of p and Q it
holds that the probability of X not
equal to y is at least their total
variation distance and furthermore there
exists an optimal coupling that achieves
the
equality uh such optimal cing may not be
uniqu may not be unique but they always
achieve this
equality okay so uh when we know the
coupling LMA Let's uh go back to the
problem of estimating the total
variation distance between two product
distributions so one natural question is
what is optimal coupling between two
product distributions p and Q if we can
find it then we can compute the total
variation
distance uh we don't know what is
optimal coupling but here is a natural
gedy coupling which seems to be optimal
so uh okay let's consider following
greedy coupling of two product
distributions p and Q we draw two nend
dimensional random vectors X and Y such
that X and Y are coupled as follows for
every index x i and Yi x i follows the
distribution pi and Yi follows the
distribution Qi we use the optimal
coupling between pi and Qi to couple XI
and Yi and for different indices they
are coupled
independently uh so this coupling seems
to be the optimal coupling but uh it is
not uh one reason is that if it is an
optimal coupling then we can easily
compute the probability of x equal to Y
in this coupling which means we can
compute the total variation distance
between p and Q exactly but the problem
is sh be
complete okay another reason another
explanation is that in this coupling X1
and y1 are correlated with each other
because they are draw from their optimal
coupling and similarly X2 and Y2 are
correlated with each
other uh X1 and X2 are independent it is
necessary because X1 and X2 should
follow the product distribution p and y1
and Y2 are also independent with each
other uh but however in general in a
general coupling X1 can be correlated
with Y2 and X2 can be correlated with y1
but in this optimal but in this gritty
coupling they are
independent so the true optimal coupling
can alze the correlation in the middle
to minimize the probability that X not
equal to y
okay so so we know the gdy coupling is
not optimal but another observation is
that although this coupling is not
optimal it is not very far away from the
optimal coupling so uh in the gitty
coupling X not equal to y greater than
the total variation distance this
inequality follows from the coupling LMA
but on the other hand this probability
that most M times the total variation
distance it can be proved by a similar
uh very simple Union Bond so in the gy
coupling the probability that X not
equal to Y by a union bond is the sum of
the probability that XI not equal to
Yi because every XI and Yi are coupled
using the optimal coupling of their
marginal distributions so this sum is
actually the sum of the total variation
distance then we use a simple fact that
the total variation distance between
marginal distribution is smaller than
the total variation distance between the
whole distribution so every every this
this total variation distance is smaller
than the total variation distance
between p and Q with summation of n
terms so they are at most n times the
total variation
distance okay this is the second
property of this gridy coupling and
finally the discrepancy of this gdy
coupling can be computed efficiently
this is because every indices are
coupled independently so in gy coupling
X not equal to Y is one minus the
probability in great coupling that x
equal to Y because every index is
coupled independently this probability
is just a product so which is very easy
to
compute now we have the three properties
of the gy coupling so uh we can give our
estimator to the total variation
distance between p and Q so our
estimator is that uh it uh instead of
estimate this total variation distance
between p and Q directly we estimate the
value of this ratio so the ratio is
defined as the probability that X not
equal to y in the optimal coupling over
the probability that X not equal to y in
the gry coupling so by coupling LMA the
numerator is just the total variation
distance and the denominator by the
third property is very easy to compute
so if we can estimate this ratio then we
just times the ratio with the uh the
denominator then we can get an estimate
estimator to the total variation
distance between p and
Q so why we should we do it uh if you uh
remember that I uh uh I just introduced
a naive estimator that can estimate the
TV distance between p and Q with
additive arror and we cannot transform
it into a relative arror estimator
because the total variation distance
between p and Q can be exponentially
more but here we estimate this ratio the
second property tells us that this this
ratio is at least one of so which is one
over polom in m so which in some sense
means this ratio is easy to estimate
with a relative
AR okay so uh what is our estimator to
this ratio so our estimator is defined
as follows so we first Define find
distribution Pi the pi is the
distribution of X in the grey coupling
conditioning on X not equal to Y so
basically Pi is a distribution Over N
dimensional random vectors for every uh
n dimensional random Vector Sigma the
the probability of Sigma in pi is equal
to uh in this gritty coupling
conditioning X not equal to Y the
probability that X takes the value
Sigma okay next we a function f which
Maps n dimensional random Vector to a
real number so this function is defined
by F Sigma is the probability in optimal
coupling x equal to Sigma and X not
equal to Y over the probability in grey
equal to Y uh and the numerator can be
written in this form and I don't give
you a proof but it's just using some
simple observation of the optimal
coupling okay and finally our estimator
is f Sigma where Sigma is a random
sample from the distribution
point so uh why does this estimator
works we can calculate the expectation
of our estimator that is with sample
Sigma from PI we look at the expected
value of f Sigma um by a you can by you
can plung this conditional distribution
into here and uh by by some calculation
you can VAR ify that the expectation is
exactly the ratio we want to estimate
and this ratio is at least one the
second property that the variance of f
of this estimator is also small this is
due to the fact that uh one can verify
that for every Sigma uh the value of f
Sigma is always between zero and one
which means the variance of this
estimator is at the most
one so given these two properties we can
have a very simple multical algorithm to
estimate this ratio because the
expectation have a one over polinomial
lower bound and the variance is small in
this case we need only need to draw
random sample of f Sigma for T times and
take the average so we sample Sigma one
Sigma 2 Sigma T independently from the
distribution Pi then calculate the value
of f Sigma 1 F Sigma 2 up to F Sigma n
then output the value uh by a chb shift
inequality we can show that uh this
return value approximate this ratio and
because we can exactly compute this
probability so we can estimate the total
variation distance between
pmq but uh to get the full algorithm we
still need to solve two problems the
first problem is how to draw a random
sample Sigma from this distribution pi
and the second problem is that given the
value of Sigma how to compute the uh
function f Sigma Okay I uh I didn't uh I
will not give the detail but the the
idea is that to compute F Sigma we only
need to compute the denominator and
because the denominator is the
probability of some event in the greedy
coupling and the greedy coupling is the
simple product distribution because we
couple every index independently so this
probability is easy to compute so it is
not a problem then to to generate a
random sample from PI perhaps one
natural idea is try rejection sampling
so say we draw random sample from gitty
coupling and reject the sample if x
equal to Y but this rejection sampling
is not efficient because the probability
of X not equal to Y may be very very
small we need to repeat exponentially
many number of times to think x equal to
X not equal to y
but it's still not a problem we can
sample PI from by using the self
reducibility so I think the the reason
is that um because Pi is defined by the
gritty coupling conditioning on some
event and the probability of this event
is easy to compute and the gritty
coupling itself is the product
distribution so this uh intuitively this
distribution Pi is easy to sample from
okay so the actual algorithm is sample
Sigma index by index uh but in this talk
I skip this
detail okay this finishes our randomized
approximation algorithm so any questions
here
okay uh good now uh next uh I will
briefly introduce our deterministic
approximation algorithm to this problem
so uh just to recall that uh in the
beginning I defined a ratio random
variable R which is the probability of
PX over the probability QX of QX H sorry
which is PX over QX where X is a random
sample from the distribution q and uh uh
and this ratio random variable R uh
encodes the total variation distance
between p and Q so uh I just I just use
the notation total variation distance of
R to denote this expectation which is
exactly the total variation distance
between p and
Q okay let's see some example now
suppose P1 and q1 are distribution or
weather and P2 and Q2 are distribution
of natural numbers one two three and
four if we calculate the the raal uh
this Ral random variable uh we can find
that these two pair of distributions
actually have the same ratio random
variable R which is this variable that
takes the value 2 over three with half
probability and takes the value four
over3 with half
probability so by this equation we
immediately know that the total
variation distance between P1 and q1 is
the same as the total variation distance
between P2 and Q2 so this raal random
variable R can preserve the full
information of the total variation
distance few the it can also it may it
may also compress some redundant
information now let's say for
example P1 P1 q1 the domain of P1 q1 are
weather the sunny day or rainy day but
the domain of P2 and Q2 are natural
numbers one two three and four actually
the domain is not very important for the
total variation distance we can replace
sunny day with a number one rainy day
with a number two the total variation
distance remains unch changed and this
uh ratio random variable R
automatically uh remove such userness
information because R is always a
discrete random variable defined on
defined over real
numbers and the second we can see that
the domain size of P2 and Q2 are four
but the domain size of R is two so in
some sense it also compress some
information
uh
okay and uh the next property of this R
ratio random variable is that it have a
good behavior for the product
distribution so let's say if R1 is the
ratio of P1 of P1 and q1 R2 is the ratio
of P2 and Q2 then we then we know that
r1. R2 is the ratio of two product
distributions here I need to explain the
notation we have two product here here
is a DOT product here is a cross product
okay so we use P1 cross P2 just to
denote the product distribution of P1
and P2 which is I defined in the
beginning of this
talk and we use r1. R2 to denote the
distribution of the product of two
independent random real numbers so say
we can sample a random uh because R1 is
a distrib is a discrete distribution
over real numbers so we can sample a
number
R1 from the distribution R1 and we
sample a random number R2 from the
distribution R2 then we take the product
of R1 and R2 so the product of two real
numbers is one real number and the
distribution of this real number is
denoted by R1 do
R2 so uh this Pro so this property tells
us that if we consider the total VAR if
they consider the ratio of product
distributions we can just the times the
ratio together
independently okay uh if we know this
property then we can have a simple
algorithm also naive algorithm to
compute the total variation distance now
for every marginal distribution pi and
Qi we can compute their raal
distribution RI here I comput the full
distribution not just draw random sample
because we want to deterministic
algorithm and we can do it because the
support of Pi and Qi is s so the support
of is also
s then next we set a raal random
variable R1 to1 to be R1 and we set
ratio random variable r122 to be r1.
R2 uh in general in I step we set R12 I
to be R12 I minus one. r i and finally
we return the total variation distance
encoded by R12
n so uh this simple algorithm actually
exactly comput the total variation
distance between p and Q uh so this is
very slow the reason is that once we uh
times two ratio together their size of
their support can be increased by a
factor of s so we do it in N steps and
finally the support of R1 to n can be
exponentially large so we uh so it will
cost us a lot of time to compute the
distribution of R1 to n
so our idea for the deterministic
approximation algorithm is that uh we
don't want we cannot compute The Rao
distribution are one to M but we somehow
compute a spotified distribution ahead
one to M and the total variation
distance encoded by a head one to n can
approximate the total variation distance
encoded by the uh real ratio R1 to M so
if we can do it we just return uh this
total variation
distance okay so here is the uh
framework of our algorithm first we
computed the raal uh random variable for
every marginal
distribution then in the first step we
let rhead one to one to be R1 and in the
second step we let we first compute Ahad
one to one times the uh times the
distribut dot the distribution R2 you
know that after this step the domain
size of this distri distribution can be
S times the domain size of of this
distribution but next we apply a spif
fire spify step we spify the domain of
the r prime one to two to get the uh the
ratio random variable ahead one 122 so
after the specification we can guarantee
the domain size of output random
variable is bmed so we do it in every
step and finally we can get the
spifi ratio distribution ahhe 1 to n and
we return the total variation distance
encoded by rhead 1 to
n so uh the key of this algorithm is
what is this spy file
sub so uh let me explain so the Spy fire
sub routine takes a input distribution R
Prime so because every ratio random
variable is a discrete distribution uh
from where every element takes the value
from real in real numbers between zero
and infinity so we have this discr
distribution and our algorithm partition
the whole interval zero to Infinity into
a set of disjoint
intervals then we then one interval may
contain many elements in this input
distribution we merging that into one
element now for example in this case the
last interval contain three elements X1
X2 and X3 we merging them into one
element the probability of this new
element is just the sum of the
probability R Prime uh sum of these
three probabilities and the value of
this element is actually the average of
uh X1 X2 and X3 with respect to the
distribution
oppr so after this spcification step we
can see that no matter how large the
domain of R Prime is the domain size of
R head is always the at most the number
intervals so we can control the domain
size of the output
distribution okay so the next question
is how to partition the interval we do
it in two steps we first partition the
interval between zero and one so we
partition it into A1 to a z A2 to A1 A3
to A2 up to am to am minus
one then we partition uh the interval
one to Infinity similarly we're just
using the number number one A1 one A2
and so
on now okay so the question is how to
partition the interval between zero and
one so we need to satisfy two conditions
the first is that the first interval
should be very small and the second
property uh roughly stats that the
length of the interval increased by a
factor 1 plus Epsilon s in every step so
the interval become longer and longer
uh in the algorithm we can set the
parameter uh Delta s to be very small
and Epsilon s to be Epsilon Over N so uh
we can show that the number of intervals
is small so which means after the
specification the domain size of the
output distribution is small we can Bond
it by n over Epsilon Times log one over
the total variation
distance and uh also we need to control
the arror introduced by the spcification
because after specification will we lose
some information and we need to show
that it does not have a huge impact to
the final total variation Distance
outputed by the algorithm so in the
paper we actually introduced a a new
metric between two ratio distributions
and we show that after one SP ification
step there the the distance between in
this metric between input distribution
and output distribution in the small and
uh and we can show that if the distance
with respect to the this metrical is
small we can show the uh final answer is
correct but here I won't give you the
detail because I think I just have one
or two minutes so so let's summarize um
in this talk we uh we we studed the
problem of approximating the total
variation distance between two product
distributions we have both randomized
algorithm and deterministic algorithm
and our algorithm can slightly go beyond
the product distribution for example the
TV distance between two micro
chains now for the open problem one open
problem is that can can we in the you
our deterministic algorithm the running
time depends on log one over the total
variation distance so can we remove this
factor or this factor is necessary for
deterministic algorithm so I don't know
about it I don't know and
the the second open problem that can we
generalize uh our technique to more
General distri butions very recently in
September there is a paper in Arab uh
that generalize our gritty coupling to
to some partial or local coupling
technique and they can uh approximate
the total varation distance between two
BS networks uh defined on the same Deck
with the bonded triways or Logan treway
or maybe all log and treway okay and the
last open question is that if there any
any relation between approximating t
distance with sampling and accounting
okay and that's all thank
[Applause]
you
questions I have a dumb question so for
the deterministic algorithm don't you
need to know the answer to set the
parameter uh we can't have a lower bound
oh you have a bound okay yeah yeah then
I guess it also begs the question what
if you have mixture models and pric
circuits then yeah uh I think our
determinate a needs requires us to
compute the conditional marginal
distributions and in general the
marginal distribution is not very easy
to compute so for example for graphical
model with unbounded TRS it's it's not
easy to compute the margin right but for
for the tractable Pro six circuits where
you have I mean what you have is really
simple protic circuit which is the
product of independent bernise MH if you
now had a sum of those yeah yeah could
you still
approximate uh the product and the
mixture of the a mixture of of
these uh I haven't thought about it yeah
maybe we can try
offline uh is there anything that you
could say about the relationship of this
work with the um like sahai and
vid's uh work on
um uh you know the deciding uh
statistical closeness or farness for uh
sampl distributions sampled by Boolean
circuits uh yes that problem is that I
know is is hard in general well it's
complete for statis I yes yes but our
yeah yes for General it's problem is
hard but our technique only works for
some very special distributions such as
a product distribution right right so
you but but none of their techniques are
your techniques I mean they have these
interesting techniques polarization kind
of Lemma yeah and I don't know if that
that would apply in general to to any
kind of distribution but whether or not
those techniques would be use for what
you're doing oh yeah yeah yeah it could
be but uh now I didn't see any directory
relations between our technique and
their technique we can try later
thanks other
questions so uh could you could you hint
how to generalize this to mark of chains
uh sorry we we our determin is to go
approximation algorithm can generalize
to mic CH so yeah just just a hint how
this uh Works sorry well so how does
this work for Mark of change just like
to okay just the high Lev idea okay yeah
uh because in Mark of change you can
compute the conditional marginal
distribution so you can do it in a pro
you can do it step by step so condition
of the value of previous step you can
compu the marginal distribution of The
Next Step then so we can maintain we
instead of ratio we we maintain some
conditional ratio so the ratio
conditioning on the total variation
distance of two micro conditioning on
one XI takes a specific value then we
can merge the conditional ratios into
the the ratios we want to
compute probably something like a
forward algorithm for
okay all right thanks swimming again
okay